>>> A STUNNING DEVELOPMENT IN
THE BUSINESS WORLD OVERNIGHT.
BOB IGER IS BACK AT THE TOP OF
DISNEY, TWO YEARS AFTER RETIRING
FROM A LEGENDARY RUN.
HE REPLACES HIS SUCCESSOR, BOB
CHAPEK AFTER THE COMPANY
SUFFERED A DISAPPOINTING
EARNINGS WITH CHAPEK HAVING A
ROCKY TENURE WITH THE PUBLIC
BATTLES WITH FLORIDA GOVERNOR
RON DeSANTIS.
CHAPEK WAS CRITICIZED FOR NOT
COMING OUT FORCEFULLY AND
IMMEDIATELY AGAINST THE NOT SAY
GAY BILL.
>> A LOT OF THESE ISSUES ARE NOT
NECESSARILY POLITICAL.
IT'S ABOUT RIGHT AND WRONG.
SO I HAPPEN TO FEEL, AND I
TWEETED AN OPINION ABOUT THIS
DON'T SAY GAY BILL IN FLORIDA.
TO ME IT WASN'T POLITICS, IT IS
WHAT IS RIGHT AND WHAT IS WRONG.
AND THAT JUST SEEMED WRONG.
IT SEEMED POTENTIALLY HARMFUL TO
KIDS.
>> LISTEN ALSO TO HOW IGER
RESPONDED EARLIER THIS YEAR WHEN
OUR FRIEND CARA SWISHER ASKED
HIM ABOUT, BY THE WAY, ABOUT
POTENTIALLY COMING BACK.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT CNBC
POLLED TEN MEDIA EXECUTIVES
ANONYMOUSLY ABOUT THEIR 2022
PREDICTIONS AND ONE WAS THAT
YOU'LL RETURN TO DISNEY.
>> AS WHAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
MICKEY MOUSE CHARACTER.
>> YES.
>> THERE ARE RUMORS THAT YOU
COULD BECOME DISNEY'S CEO AGAIN.
>> THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
I WAS CEO FOR A LONG TIME.
YOU CAN'T GO HOME AGAIN, I'M
GONE.
>> REALLY?
IT'S HAPPENED BEFORE.
>> I GAVE MY ID UP, MY NAME TAG
UP, MY OFFICE, MY EMAIL ADDRESS
IT'S ALL GONE.
I THINK IF I WANTED TO RUN A
COMPANY I'D STILL BE RUNNING
DISNEY.
NO, I DID THAT.
>> NOW HE IS.
JOINING US NOW, SARAH FISHER.
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE YOU.
I WAS READING THROUGH YOUR
REPORTING THIS MORNING.
CHAPEK HAS HAD A ROCKY RUN, BUT
THE FACT THAT IGER IS COMING
BACK TO DISNEY TO HELP GET IT
OFF ITS KNEES, THEY FACE SO MANY
TROUBLES.
TELL US WHAT YOU KNOW.
>> I THINK THESE TWO HAVE HAD A
ROCKY RELATIONSHIP THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
A REPORT CAME OUT IN "THE NEW
YORK TIMES" THAT SORT OF
ASSERTED THAT BOB IGER WANTED TO
COME BACK AND BRING MORE CONTROL
TO THE COMPANY AMID THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC, I THINK
THE EXECUTIVES TO BE ON THE SAME
PAGE EVER SINCE.
BUT WHAT THIS REALLY SUGGESTS TO
ME, WEAKNESS ON THE SIDE OF THE
DISNEY BOARD.
BOB IGER HAD YEARS AS A CEO TO
CHOOSE A SUCCESSOR.
AND NOW, HIM COMING BACK, BOB
CHAPEK DIDN'T EVEN GET A PROPER
GOOD-BYE.
TO DO THAT PROCESS AGAIN AND
CHOOSE ANOTHER SUCCESSOR IS
PRETTY OUTSTANDING TO ME.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE FACT THAT
BOB CHAPEK'S CONTRACT WAS VOTED
ON BY THE BOARD TO BE EXTENDED
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO.
>> I REMEMBER BOB'S BOOK A FEW
MONTHS AGO AND HE WROTE IN IT
THE WAY YOU DO ANYTHING IS THE
WAY YOU DO EVERYTHING.
THAT EXAMPLE ON HOW TO DEAL WITH
THE BILL IN FLORIDA, CHAPEK
WAFFLED FOR A LONG TIME, AND
EMPLOYEES GOT SO MAD AND LEFT
AND WALKED OUT.
AND IGER SAID RIGHT AWAY, NO,
THIS IS WRONG.
THIS ISN'T POLITICS.
IS THAT EMBLEMATIC OF HIS
LEADERSHIP?
>> I THINK SO.
YOU'RE POINTING TO ONE OF THE
MOST CONTENTIOUS POINTS BETWEEN
THE TWO.
AT THE TIME, BOB IGER SAID THAT
THAT IS SOMETHING HE FULLY
DISAGREED WITH, AND DISNEY'S
LEADERSHIP UNDER CHAPEK WAS
WAFFLING, WHICH PUT THEM AT ODDS
PUBLICALLY.
SO BOB IGER WAS A MORE DECISIVE
LEADER MORE INTUNE TO THE
CULTURE AT DISNEY.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT BOB
CHAPEK HAS BEEN FAILING THE PAST
TWO YEARS.
DISNEY HAD GROWN AT ONE POINT TO
HAVE THE SUBSCRIBER BASE SURPASS
NETFLIX'S.
WHILE THEY HAD A BAD QUARTER THE
TREND LINES WEREN'T NEW.
STREAMING LOSSES HAD BEEN M
MOUNTING AND WALL STREET WAS
FRUSTRATED WITH IT.
BUT THESE ARE TREND LINES
HAPPENING THE PAST FEW YEARS.
TO ME I'M SHOCKED THIS
REPLACEMENT IS HAPPENING SO
QUICKLY AFTER CHAPEK'S CONTRACT
WAS JUST RENEWED.
>> THERE'S ALWAYS WHAT'S BEING
REPORTED AND WHAT WE HEAR ABOUT
IN THE PRESS.
AND THERE'S BEHIND THE SCENES.
IS THERE SOMETHING BEHIND THE
SCENES WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT?
>> Reporter: TWO THINGS.
ONE ACTIVISTS AND INVESTORS ARE
MOUNTING BIGGER POSITIONS WITHIN
DISNEY.
THE DAN LOBE FIGHT GOT PUBLIC
WHEN HE TRIED TO PRESSURE
DISNEY'S BOARD TO MAYBE COME UP
WITH NEW LEADERSHIP BUT ALSO TO
SPIN OUT ESPN PLUS AND BOB
CHAPEK WAS ABLE TO STAVE THAT
OFF.
BUT NEW REPORTING BY "THE
WASHINGTON JOURNAL" ABOUT A
DIFFERENT ACTIVIST INVESTOR
PUTTING PRESSURE AT THIS TIME.
AND THE TENSIONS BETWEEN THE TWO
EXECUTIVES BEHIND THE SCENES
SOURCES TOLD ME WAS PALPABLE.
IT WASN'T ONE BLOW UP FIGHT BUT
THEY WEREN'T COMMUNICATING AND
IGER WAS NOT PUBLICALLY
ENDORSING CHAPEK'S STRATEGY ALL
THAT MUCH.
>> THANKS VERY MUCH FOR BEING
WITH US.